hi there's the copper here to talk about
language learning if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe and a lot of
these videos sort of come to my mind
based on experiences that I'm having in
my latest language learning and devorah
which right now is Arabic so today I'm
going to talk about mistakes errors
their role in language learning and what
we do about them and others have just
related to errors so I mentioned on
Twitter that I was lined up to pay in a
store and a couple behind me we're
speaking Arabic so of course my ears
pick up I haven't spoken any Arabic so I
turn to them and I say you know I'm
learning Arabic although I can't speak
and then I tried to say that in Arabic
and I said ooh that is sooo al-arabiya
which is wrong because I supposed to say
uterus a blue dress sewages learn who
dress ooh and then log I can't even
lah-lah or la hata or whatever the
language Arab Al Arabiya but Lea con la
la hasta Pia Tejada that just to talk
which apparently is not the right thing
to say either and so there were some
comments correcting at least find and
also I showed an excerpt of me using my
iPad to learn Arabic and of course the
text-to-speech voice came through and
people also pointed out that the
text-to-speech was incorrect in some
cases which is also true
now the question ok so the point here is
that to me it doesn't matter these
Corrections are not going to correct me
I will not necessarily improve as a
result of this individual correction the
fact that the text-to-speech is wrong
doesn't have a great influence on me
because we learn primarily through
massive input these lessons that I'm
using the many stories where I will use
the text-to-speech to give me an idea
how the word is pronounced
you know the number of times I listen to
that versus the number of times that I'm
on my bicycle are walking around and
listening to the actual human voice
saying it correctly you know that
incorrect input is a relatively small
amount it really doesn't matter
I thank the people for correcting me I
don't know defense to it but it's it's
relatively meaningless and and the whole
idea with with mistakes you know which
are a big part of language learning we
have tests drills and then you look at
the back of the book and you'll see
which ones you got right which ones you
didn't get right and I've always
disliked these because it puts pressure
on you to get it right and and in many
cases you're not yet in a position to
get it right they very often in these
language books they'll start off in less
than one they teach you a bunch of stuff
and then they right away want to test
you on it and you haven't got much of a
chance of getting it right one advantage
on on a computer on my iPad where we
have flashcards were asked things that
you get an immediate feedback
it was right or it was wrong in whatever
which of the five activities that I'm
using so that makes it better
you don't have to wait till the end and
all the while that I'm doing these
flashcards where I'm asked questions I'm
getting them wrong to me is just
exposure
it's just interaction with the language
the issue of error doesn't matter and
there's a lot of research that's been
done by stephen krashen and benito mason
in japan which shows that error
correction has little relatively little
impact on improving people's output that
massive input listening in reading is
far more important than correction and
there are even people say well you know
but kids they the only way that kids
learn to speak correctly is if their
parents correct them which of course is
total nonsense because parents correct
very little of their children's speech
and children learned from their peers
otherwise children of immigrants would
speak like their parents but they don't
they speak like their peers their
friends at school so I think the whole
idea of errors error correction
thing is overdone in our school system
in Canada we go through ten years of
French instruction with all kinds of
tests and probably the better students
do well in the test and yet at the end
of it very few people can speak so the
errors as a focus of language learning
mistakes I think it's a mistake to focus
on mistakes mistakes don't matter we
shouldn't get seven out of ten five out
of ten on tests we should just treat
interacting with the language as
exposure and as I've said before the
language we start to notice different
things at different times different
things kind of click at different times
and when we're aware of certain things
then we start to notice other things and
sometimes we just improve even without
noticing the fact that we're improving
through additional exposure to the
language now I will sometimes do
deliberate things that link for example
I will save phrases that contain a
certain grammatical structure that I'm
having trouble with so then I can review
them in a concentrated manner but just
by reviewing them once or five times or
ten times doesn't mean I corrected my
error but it's part of that exposure it
gives me some concentrated exposure and
at some point the brain will basically
have that click in as being the natural
way to say that so you know and I've had
the experience as a tutor online in
English I mentioned this before I had a
German learner of English who kept on
saying
Berlin for Berlin I said why would you
say Berlin in in German it's believed so
the accent is on the second syllable so
in English he's just Berlin oh thank you
thank you and of course he continued
saying Berlin the whole time and you can
correct if we're staying with Germans
Germans have a tendency to say like I
have lived in canvas since many
years which of course is wrong it copies
the German structure and you can correct
them and they'll continue doing that
until at some point it just clicks in as
being natural I have lived in Canada for
many years so all I'm saying is that the
focus on errors being concerned about
errors thinking that making mistakes is
gonna somehow damage you I think is
mistaken we need to focus on massive
input and again those well intended
well-intentioned people who are
correcting my Arabic that's very kind of
you I appreciate the fact that there are
people encouraging me in my Arabic but I
think that if I can continue to listen
and read and do the various activities
that I do it linked eventually I'll get
a natural sense move without having to
remember that I was corrected at some
point I will naturally improve and some
of those things will kick kick in so
there you have some thoughts on error is
error correction the importance of
errors or the lack of importance of
errors it's just part of the process so
thank you for listening
[Music]